The world's pictures of ships go back thousands and thousands of years.
In Egypt, the oldest examples of sailing craft go back 3,500 years before the common era.
That was in Mesopotamia.
You go and cut a few slices. Go on. From the log.
You want me to slice up a log? Why?
Just slice 'em.
Mm-hmm.
Huh?
Yes. Yes!
You can only imagine that's how it was.
We can't be sure about mankind's history until written language was created.
was created and then it's right here at about the same time that writing came into being
so from now on we have our our use of the wheel and the sail and writing well children ready to
explore a little adventures calling joe people need adventures all this exploring why don't
they settle down stay home what a dull world if there weren't any new inventions new discoveries
lucky for us that man's been curious from his beginning where would we be today if we weren't
Driven by desire to explore, to know about things, to discover the world.
Now back to our story.
An empire is founded in Egypt on the banks of the Nile, on the island of Crete.
The heart of Europe, a great civilization is developing also.
With its sailing ships, it rules the seas.
Aha, there's a Phoenician ship.
Prepare for combat.
Ship, prepare for combat.
Make a very boat ride by Sidians.
Kings of the oceans, the seas are Phoenicians. Sail on.
Stop, the seas are ours.
Now you can drink it up.
Ah, yes, it's true.
Two maritime powers rivaled Crete for mastery of the seas.
The Phoenicians, in what is now Lebanon, and the Mycenaeans, in Greece.
This rivalry was to go on for centuries, until one day, a certain thing happened.
What happened was really terrible, children.
It took place on Thera, one of the islands of Crete.
Fargo of wine for Thera.
You can't unload it.
Hmm, a very good vintage.
Well, one way to find out. Cheers!
Just to be sure, I will have one more sip.
... of ash spread over thousands of miles in a wide circle.
This was the end of the great Minoan civilization of Crete.
The Greeks and Phoenicians were to dominate the Mediterranean Sea.
They tell the story of a certain Greek named Ulysses who went on a voyage of ten years.
Met all kinds of strange creatures during his adventures.
A famous historian, Herodotus, says six centuries before our era,
era and the pharaoh of egypt neko the second summoned a certain phoenician captain i'm informed
you're a courageous and skillful sailor would you be willing to sail down the red sea and go
completely around the african continent and then return to the mediterranean well yes sire on one
condition the reward be equal to the mission and the danger to make a trip of 25 000 kilometers of
unexplored route with their technology do you realize children they knew almost nothing about
And the voyage lasted three years, we're told. A century later, it was the unbelievable voyage of Hanno, a Phoenician, leaving from Carthage.
It's Hanno and Himilco, my two captains. Look at my ship. It's a wreck. The world happened to you two.
It's those Mycenaeans. They're better armed than we are. Yes, we're just lucky we made it.
Well, come on, you'd better put some proper clothes on.
Fine rye polyps!
Finest fabrics for my two unfortunate captains.
I'm not sure it's in stock.
Jail is direct from Crete, none better for high quality walking.
I'm a genuine Egyptian, please inspect my superb coats.
Presentable now, so I suppose we can sit down and have a chat about big rivers in certain
regions of Africa, where the rivers are so full of gold that if you discover one or two
of them your fortunes made, sail our ships past the Pillars of Hercules?
Today, our name for the place is the Straits of Gibraltar.
There's nothing to it, a passage running between Gibraltar and Africa.
It's dangerous.
But see, a hundred dangers might come up.
These Carthaginians are self-stopping them.
They get rich.
We'll stop them.
Maybe we can be rich if we go with them.
Selling beyond the pillars of Hercules, crazy. Crazy. It's the end of the world.
Why have you done it?
Even Poseidon, the Lord of the Sea, wouldn't attempt that. He'd give up.
Nope, the world ends and the sea spills into a deep pit.
sea serpents nobody will go did a minute he had a hydra man would be crazy to fight to be strong
as hercules well thinking about it all my blood runs cold gives a man a thirst for a drop of mead
what about it one cup yeah these buns are real and they're dangerous no there's a lot of superstitious
nonsense however the beautiful nareeds will protect that's right these sea girls good looking
and they're dolphins i've seen those with my own eyes well him will go what do you say
Ha ha! Hanno says, "Let's go!"
We'd be happy to be your guides for part of the way.
Done!
That was it.
Maestro, why were they so scared? Was it because there were monsters, or what?
Well, they thought the Earth was flat, and they would come to the very brink and tumble off.
Hey dummies, we know the Earth is round.
Oh, yes, today we know that.
But a Greek mathematician, the Great Pythagoras, realized the Earth was a ball, but nobody would believe him.
The p-p-p-p-hercules that turns against us. We can't fight it. And if we do fight it, then we're done for.
We'll put in here and wait till the wind is favorable.
The wind is coming from that direction. That's the zephyr. We've got to wait for the euro in the other direction.
It's changed.
It's all off the boat with us aboard. We'll end up sea monsters breakfast. I hate it when this happens.
The what monster?
The monster always returns. Why did I tell you the monster?
Like dolphins, only big. Any trouble for us?
Not true.
Then I make big waves campsite the ship, and then the fish food you'll see, you'll see!
So far, you're the only one making waves.
I don't be here, you're watching the sun.
And if we go on, the water will begin to boil.
We'll come and we'll run aground, and on shore, there's nothing but sand.
We'll shrivel up and die!
Declare the coast!
Then we'll be dead from hunger, and besides, we'll all be dead!
There's land! We'll find fresh water and food right there!
Wish I'd stayed home.
Like us.
But he's black.
This river.
Before the common era, the Sahara was the site of prosperous, pastoral civilizations.
The historian Herodotus tells us that these people fought against another people.
The Caramantes, no-bads, who roamed over North Africa.
We're all rich to keep going south. We'll all be killed.
We won't go with him.
We'll take the ship and gather up as much gold as we can.
We head straight home, and we're rich.
What about the captain?
He takes a long swim.
Grab the ship.
That's how we punish mutineers, men.
You're the one who's gonna die, but we're generous, Hanno.
Jump overboard and swim the rest of the way.
I'm going to let all of you live.
Since you're in a hurry to get back, I'll make you the same offer: swim back.
Tomorrow we explore.
We'd better be very careful.
Telling what we'll run into out here.
Hey, wait, children!
Well, then they must be dwarves, huh?
No, humans!
We're gonna be Pygmy's lunch, they'll chop us into the little chest.
We'd better be going just to leave.
So now what?
Well, there's too many, so we'll wait until there's a chance to get away tonight.
In my life, he's a king.
A century later, a famous Greek astronomer, Pythias, would make another voyage of discovery.
Only this time, it was to the north. He encountered the Hyperboreans.
The Hyper-what?
Boreans were a certain people in the north, and the Hyperboreans, well, they lived farther north.
Yes, you going away again?
Yes, I'm going up north this time.
Go too far up north, you might freeze.
But now the days are long.
Yes, what a shame. Because during the day, we work. It's at night that we rest.
Anyway, have a good time.
We go north how much longer the days are.
Yes, Pythias. I've also noticed the days are much colder. We're going much farther.
We're going to where the days are so long, there isn't going to be any night.
No night at all. You must be dreaming impossible.
I mean, the sun has to set each night to come up in the morning again.
Not so. If the Earth is round, as a number of philosophers claim,
N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N-N
round like a ball. Here, where we are in the far north, the sun is level with us. It goes
around, but never below the horizon. It never sets.
And so here, they never see night. Never see the stone.
Sure they do. Look, in winter, it's just the opposite. The sun is below. It doesn't rise.
It goes back to the south below the horizon.
I wouldn't want to live far north with no sun.
Look, Pythias, what do you say we go on home now? We saw Thule. Let's make it before nightfall.
Right. Let's go home.
Six months? Ha ha!
All you explorers full of tall stories.
"Listen, everybody! He says they're a night six months long! Who'd fall for life?"
...children that many centuries before our time, they began to realize the Earth is round.
And Pythias calculated quite precisely the distance he had traveled,
and a century later, a wise Greek, Erasthenes, mathematically calculated the circumference of the Earth.
They began to realize that even old Herodotus didn't have all of the answers when he said:
"The Earth is round and surrounded by oceans, but Athens is here, right at the center.
To the north, it's only ice and snow inhabited by Hyperboreans,
while to the east, there is Asia.
It stops at the Urals and the Indies,
but Africa is certainly crowded with elephants and pygmies and giraffes
with very, very, very long necks, et cetera, et cetera.
Yes, well, it's pretty clear to see, children,
that it's only the start of man's understanding.
Our ancestors went a long, long way,
and some of those voyages, well, we're going to go along with them.